[Music]
when my son and I moved in here
it wasn't as warm as we hoped
okay I'm gonna light a vanilla candle
and it's going to be a game changer
after midnight
we need your help
it's time to assemble the Dream Team
we find someone who can communicate with
these ghosts
people used to eat here I told you she's
good oh it's a dining room
I found a professor who else wanted
mansions I've been dying to go to this
place for years
mystery lurks around every corner
I can show you what happened but it will
cost you
three dollars
what silent robbery who said that
you're not that scary you're really not
terrifying can you turn it around just
while I finish this thank you
guys
is anybody else
if we don't solve this mystery
we're stuck here for eternity
surprise you're all in for a treat
no no no no
no oh come on
[Music]